so let's just review what we've seen
with budget lines let's say i'm making
twenty dollars a month so my income is
twenty dollars per month let's say per
month
my
the price of chocolate is two is one
dollar per bar one dollar per bar and
the price of fruit is two dollars per
pound two dollars per pound and we've
already done this before but i'll just
redraw a budget line
so this axis let's say this is the
quantity of chocolate i could have
picked it either way and that is the
quantity quantity of fruit not quantity
of four the quantity of fruit if i spent
all my money on chocolate i could buy 20
bars of chocolate a month so that is 20
this is 10 right over here at these
prices if i spend all of my money on
fruit i could buy 10 pounds per month so
this is 10
so that's 10 pounds per month that would
be 20. and so i have a budget line that
looks like this
i have a budget line that looks like
this and the equation of this budget
line is going to be well i could write
it like this my budget 20
is going to be equal to the price of
chocolate which is 1 times the quantity
of chocolate so this is one times the
quantity of chocolate
plus the price of fruit which is two
times the quantity of fruit
times the quantity of fruit and if i
want to write this explicitly in terms
of my quantity of chocolate since i put
that on my vertical axis and that tends
to be the more dependent axis i can just
subtract 2 times the quantity of fruit
from both sides and i and i can flip
them and i get my quantity of chocolate
is equal to 20 minus 2 times my quantity
of fruit and i get this budget line
right over there well we've also looked
at the idea of an indifference curve so
for example let's say i'm sitting at
some point on my budget line where i
have let's say i am consuming 18 bars of
chocolate and one pound of fruit
18 and you can verify that makes sense
it's going to be 18 plus 2 which is 20.
so let's say i'm at this point on my
budget line
18 pounds so 18 bars of chocolate so
this is in bars
and one pound of fruit per month so that
is one and this is in pounds pounds
and this is chocolate
chocolate and this is fruit right over
here
well we know we have this idea of an
indifference curve there's different
combinations of chocolate and fruit to
which we are indifferent to which we
will get the same exact total utility
and so we can plot all of those points
i'll do it in white it could look
something like this i'll do it as a
dotted line it makes it a little bit
easier should we draw it like this
so let's say i'm indifferent between any
of
any of these points any of those points
right over there let me draw a little
bit better so between any of these
points right over there so for example i
could have 18 bars of chocolate and one
pound of fruit or i could have i could
have let's say that is four bars of
chocolate and let's see four bars of
chocolate and roughly 8 pounds of fruit
i'm indifferent i get the same exact
total utility
now am i maximizing my total utility at
either of those points well we've
already seen that anything to the top
right of our indifference curve of this
white curve right over here let me label
this this is our indifference curve
indifference curve everything to the top
right of our indifference curve is
preferable we're going to get more total
utility so let me color that in so
everything to the top right of our
indifference curve is going to be
preferable so all of these other points
on our budget line even a few points
below our budget line where we would
actually save money are preferable so
either any of so either of these points
are not going to maximize our total
utility we can maximize our total
utility at all of these other points in
between along our budget line so to
actually maximize our total utility what
we want to do is find a point on our
budget line that is just tangent that is
that that is just that is exactly
touches at exactly one point one of our
indifference curves we can have an
infinite number of indifference curves
there could be an indifference curve
that looks like that there could be
another indifference curve that looks
like that all that says is that we are
indifferent between any points on this
curve and so there is an indifference
curve that is touches exactly this
budget line it or exactly touches the
line at one point and so i might have an
indifference curve that looks like this
we do this in a
vibrant color in magenta
so i could have an indifference curve
that looks like this
and because it's tangent it touches in
exactly one point and also the slope of
my indifference curve which we've
learned was the marginal rate of
substitution is the exact same as the
slope as the slope of our budget line
right over there which we learned
earlier was the relative price so this
right here is the optimal the optimal
allocation on our budget line
that right here is optimal and how do we
know it is optimal
well there is no other point on the
budget line that is to the top right in
fact every other point on the but every
other point on our budget line is to the
bottom left of this indifference curve
so every other point on our on our
budget line is not preferable so
remember everything below everything
below an indifference curve so all of
the shaded area let me actually do
another color because the indifference
curve we are indifferent but everything
below an indifference curve so all of
this area in green obviously is not
preferable and every other point on the
budget line is not preferable to that
point right over there because that's
the only point or i guess you could say
every other point on our budget line is
not preferable to the to the points on
the indifference curve so they're also
not preferable to that point right over
there which actually is on the
indifference curve now let's think about
what happens
let's think about what happens if the
price of fruit were to go down so the
price of fruit were to go from two
dollars
to one dollar to one dollar per pound so
the price of fruit went from two to one
dollar then our actual budget line will
look different our new budget line i'll
do it in blue would look like this if we
spend all our money on chocolate we
could buy 20 bars if we spent all of our
money on fruit at the new price we could
buy 20 pounds of fruit so our new budget
line
a new budget line would look something
like that
would look something like that so that
is our new budget line
new
new budget new budget line so now what
would be the optimal allocation of our
dollars or the best combination that we
would buy well we would do the exact
same exercise we would assuming that we
were we had we had data on all of these
all of these indifference curves we
would find the indifference curve that
is exactly tangent to our new budget
line so let's say that
let's say that this point right over
here is exactly tangent to another
indifference curve
so just like that so there's another
indifference curve that looks like that
let me draw it like a little bit neater
so it looks something like that it looks
something like that and so based on how
the price if we assume we have access to
these you know these many many many many
indifference curves we can now see based
on how a pr
all else equal how a change in the price
of fruit
changed the quantity of fruit we
demanded because now our optimal spend
is this point on our new budget line
which looks like it's about which looks
like it's about well give or take about
10 pounds of fruit so all of a sudden
when we were so let's think about just
the fruit everything else we're holding
equal so just the fruit let's do when
the price was two
the quantity demanded was eight pounds
and now when the price is one the
quantity demanded is ten pounds and so
what we're actually doing and once again
we're kind of looking at the exact same
ideas from different directions before
we looked at it in terms of marginal
utility per dollar and we thought about
how you maximize it and we were able to
change the prices and then figure out
and derive a demand curve from that here
we're just looking at it from a slightly
different lens but they really are all
of the same ideas
but by if assuming we had access to a
bunch of indifference curves we can see
how a change in price changes our budget
line and that how that would change the
optimal quantity we would want of a
given of a given product so for example
we could keep doing this and we could
plot our our new demand curve so i could
do a demand curve now for fruit at least
i have two points on that demand curve
so if this is the price of fruit and
this is the quantity demanded of fruit
when the price is two quantity is eight
when the price is two the quantity
demanded is eight and when the price is
actually let me do a little bit
different
when the price is two
and these aren't to scale the quantity
demanded is eight and then actually do
it here is eight and these aren't to
scale but when the price is one the
quantity demanded is ten so two eight
quantity demanded is ten
quantity demanded is 10. and so our
demand curve these are two points on it
but we could keep changing it up
assuming if we had access to a bunch of
indifference curves we could keep
changing it up and eventually plot our
demand curve that looks something that
might look something like that